[Música]
y
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa hoy desde
el parque de la biblia en parís en la
primera parte de esta edición les
explicaremos la actual crisis de los
servicios de urgencias en el país esto
se ha traducido por huelgas y
manifestaciones luego iremos a marsella
donde también hablaremos de salud aunque
salud de los océanos y terminaremos por
la historia de la sala de cine más
antigua del mundo que todavía está en
funcionamiento
[Música]
la crisis de los servicios de urgencia
en todo el país ha venido agravándose
más con el cierre de camas y la falta de
mano de obra en los establecimientos
donde los servicios de urgencias están
saturados han tratado de encontrar
maneras de seguir atendiendo pacientes
ejemplo de esto en la salud allí hay una
interna en medicina que va a visitar a
los pacientes y trabaja de la mano con
un doctor que ofrece tele consulta
con el botiquín de primeros auxilios al
hombro junto a morett llega a atender un
reporte de malestar
cuando la esposa de este hombre jubilado
llamo al 15 número de emergencias
médicas enviaron la unidad móvil de
teleconsulta del samu
el estudiante de quinto grado de
medicina inicia el cuestionario médico
para aprobación y registra los síntomas
un electrocardiograma completa está pre
consulta todos los datos son enviados a
un médico que se conecta desde cherbourg
a 50 kilómetros de distancia
'nos es muy simple
para terminar el examen una revisión con
estetoscopio que el médico escucho a la
distancia
escucho perfectamente los pulmones
escucho perfectamente que hay un edema a
nivel pulmonar cuando el samu le propuso
esa solución a janine en cobo ella no lo
dudo pensé que era mejor estar seguros y
saber que estaba pasando porque yo
estaba muy preocupada esta mañana no se
trata de una urgencia vital pero el
médico prefiere remitir a julian gogo al
hospital para unos exámenes adicionales
en este caso si enviamos al paciente al
hospital para que se haga un balance en
urgencias pero hay muchas situaciones en
las que justamente podemos evitar que el
paciente tenga que ir a urgencias
haciendo un diagnóstico a domicilio
durante sus turnos recorre cientos de
kilómetros a lo largo de este
departamento donde hacen falta médicos
esto lleva la medicina a los lugares a
los que ya no puede llegar a causa de la
de certificación médica y también
permite de saturar las salas de
urgencias que actualmente están
sobrecargadas la mancha es un
departamento pionero en unidades de
telemedicina el primer balance semestral
reportó 709 intervenciones 216
transferencias a urgencias y hasta un 70
por ciento de ingresos evitaron todas
las llamadas al número de emergencias
médicas son atendidas en este centro de
xantolo donde se hace el triaje entre
ayuda médica urgente o no urgente foto
en el caso de todas las peticiones de
ayuda no programadas que necesitan un
médico general el encargado es el médico
regulador liberal
un médico que puede enviar la unidad
móvil
para la jefa del servicio de urgencias
de sant lo estas unidades móviles son
una respuesta pero no la panacea es una
de las soluciones ya que por ahora no
podemos paliar la falta de médicos
generales en el territorio pero no
resuelve nuestros problemas porque
todavía hay muchos pacientes que llegan
de manera espontánea a urgencias porque
no tienen otra solución otras
limitaciones en algunas áreas la
conexión a internet es inexistente o
demasiado mala para realizar una tele
consulta la crisis de los servicios de
urgencias también repercute en el
bienestar físico y mental del personal
médico un 62% padecería de un síndrome
de agotamiento profesional tanto así que
muchos de ellos ya rechazan de plano
trabajar en hospitales públicos
escuchamos en el siguiente informe los
testimonios de algunas de estas
la sala de urgencias las afirma que es
un lugar habitual para el doctor heller
desde hace 35 años pero después de una
carrera en los hospitales públicos ahora
ejerce en una clínica privada y
trabaja como médico de urgencias liberal
aquí sólo ingresan 80 pacientes al día
algo totalmente distinto al hospital
desea
su último lugar de trabajo desde donde
dice que llegó con los nervios de punta
uno no sabe cuántos pacientes tendrá que
atender en la mañana que quedaron de la
noche anterior o ultimadamente era
frecuente encontrarse con 25 pacientes
en la mañana que no habían podido ser
ubicados cuando llegué aquí me
reconcilié por completo con mi profesión
ante las dificultades presupuestarias y
administrativas el doctor heller salió
del hospital público algo disgustado hay
una máquina infernal que es gasta y que
maltrata el personal sanitario y
entonces el personal maltrata a los
pacientes porque no tienen los medios
para hacer su trabajo eso fue lo que yo
quise dejar atrás tuve suficiente
viaja máximo raffo colgó su bata de
médico de urgencias hace siete meses
causa
ser médico de urgencias es una vocación
pero después de cuatro años en el
hospital de la vall big macs sing
decidió renunciar a pesar de tener un
equipo unido al final es más difícil
para la persona que se va porque uno
tiene la sensación de abandonar a sus
colegas a sus equipos y de dejarlos en
una situación difícil se siente como si
uno estuviera abandonando el barco
jacques maximin raffo todavía hace
turnos en el hospital de la vall pero
pasa la mayor parte de su tiempo en ese
centro de salud en parís
aquí trabaja como médico general
aquí se atiende un paciente cada cuarto
de hora y no hay ninguna tarea
administrativa muy distinto a su
anterior rutina en los servicios de
urgencias una vez que uno se ha
encargado de su paciente que ha hecho un
diagnóstico y ha establecido los
primeros tratamientos que es el trabajo
de un médico de urgencias después hay
que pasar el triple de tiempo
simplemente tratando de encontrar una
cama aquí el paciente llega a mi
consultorio me presenta su problema
médico y se va una vez que le he hecho
una orden fija máximo jefe no descarta
volver a ponerse su bata de médico de
urgencias si algún día mejoran las
condiciones
ahora nos trasladamos a marsella y su
región porque allí hay una empresa que
lucha por preservar el ecosistema marino
del litoral mediterráneo para lograrlo
crían peces para repoblar todas las
zonas afectadas por la actividad humana
[Música]
es una mañana de pesca especial para
llorar cardano y su hijo hoy no van a en
busca de grandes presas sino de unas
infinitamente pequeñas en cada una de
estas trampas que reúnen con paciencia
hay minúsculas larvas de peces casi
invisibles a simple vista
estas larvas de peces están amenazadas
por la contaminación la sobrepesca y los
depredadores al recogerlas gerard ayuda
a su preservación la mayoría es devorada
y nosotros recogiendo las en esa etapa
en las que sean tan pequeñas y en las
que el 90% habrían sido devoradas y
poniéndolas a salvo las protegemos de la
depredación
transportadas a una temperatura estable
a las hieleras las larvas de peces se
dirigen hacia marsella a unos 30
kilómetros de distancia este pequeño
laboratorio es una guardería de peces
única en el mundo aquí también se
encargará de las larvas y las mantendrán
a salvo hasta que lleguen a la edad
adulta
de esas aficiones milímetros de gonzález
que sexual
en estos acuarios cientos de pequeños
peces costeros podrían crecer con calma
aquí las probabilidades de supervivencia
de estos mejores por ejemplo son del 80%
son animales que tienen unos dos meses
aquí tenemos dorada real estas son las
más pequeñas y aquí arriba tenemos una
decena de congresos en esos dos acuarios
estos animales fueron capturados a
finales del año pasado y comienzos de
éste en estos bidones azules los peces
están en su última etapa de crecimiento
una formación
[Música]
aquí no hay reproducción no es un
criadero el objetivo de esta guardería
es reparar la naturaleza y devolverle
sus especies costeras amenazadas por la
actividad humana cada año los biólogos
liberan cuidadosamente entre 2 y 3 mil
peces que ya son lo suficientemente
grandes para poder sobrevivir
[Música]
el hecho de repoblar la especie verlos
regresar al mar abierto y al liberarlos
ver cómo se mezclan con peces que tienen
la misma edad y que ya estaban en ese
medio y no poder distinguir cuál creció
en la guardería y cuál se quedó en la
naturaleza es una gran satisfacción
porque ahí se ve realmente que se hizo
un buen trabajo al aumentar las
posibilidades de supervivencia de estos
peces la guardería vuelve a crear
recursos para los pescadores y vida para
el litoral se necesitan muchas más como
está en 50 años la mitad de la fauna
marina habrá desaparecido
terminemos allí mismo en la costa azul
más precisamente en la ciudad cerca de
marsella para hablar de cine allí está
el líder en la sala de cine más antigua
del mundo tiene 123 años de historia y
está estrechamente ligada a los hermanos
línea en el siguiente reportaje
descubramos este mágico lugar
érase una vez un mítico cinema con vista
al mar el teatro edén es el cine más
antiguo del mundo y sigue aún en
funcionamiento este es el afiche de la
primera función el 22 de marzo de 1899
tres años después de que los hermanos
línea inventara en el cinematógrafo
su padre tenía una propiedad en la
ciudad el palacio línea fue en esta
residencia vacacional donde rodaron su
primer film
esta es una copia de la máquina que
sirvió para las primeras proyecciones en
el teatro en la sala de cine dabo la
sala de cine nació de lo que salía de
estructurado en tres etapas terna
para el esta sala de columnas y balcones
de estilo italiano es sagrada
yo vengo todos los días y cada día
siento la misma emoción como entrando a
un templo porque aquí nació una
civilización la civilización de la
imagen y es en la pantalla del edén que
se vieron las primeras imágenes en
movimiento con un orgullo para el
proyeccionista su cabina ha atravesado
los siglos
tenemos suerte de disponer aún de
material para proyecciones de celuloide
en 16 milímetros y 35 milímetros aunque
también tenemos las tecnologías más
recientes para proyección digital
proyecta para nosotros la primera
película que se convirtió en leyenda del
cine llegada del tren a la estación de
la ciudad
la estación poco ha cambiado los
pasajeros que llegan de marsella
desembarcan sobre el mismo andén que sus
ancestros en ese lugar nos espera el
bisnieto de willy mira
es ahí que comprendo que la imagen que
las cámaras se debían ponerse en cierto
punto para dar esa sensación de
movimiento la cámara está al costado y
no al frente de la locomotora la gente
vio que ese tren llegaba sobre ellos fue
una emoción muy impactante que nos
subyuga y en éxito comenzó ahí y luego
dio la vuelta al mundo
la pequeña estación se volvió famosa
tras ser la educación de este primer
film pero el eden estuvo en riesgo de
desaparecer cerró sus puertas en 1982 y
fue abandonado durante 30 años
voluntarios y estrellas del cine como
claudia cardinale se movilizaron para
salvarlo fue restaurado y volvió a
público en 2013 pienso el mítico ni bien
es feliz elegir me aleje de filmes que
bien que te ate asociación su cima un
fuerte equipo para una asociación de
nivel
la sala de cine más antigua del mundo
acoge varios eventos entre ellos el
festival del primer film francófono
tanto cineastas como actores aprovechan
para regresar al origen del séptimo arte
dándole de nuevo al edén el lugar que
merece
hasta aquí esta edición de francia
enfoque gracias por habernos acompañado
continúen con nuestra programación en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]